Ron Kessler your new book you say that
president Trump's bravado exaggeration
and controversial comments
rather than being haphazard or a means
to the end and you say that 80% of the
time the staff says he's got a plan that
he sticks with but 20% he wakes up and
goes a whole different direction talk
about Donald Trump the deal maker you
know he's like a boxer he's always
diverting attention
bobbing and weaving counterpunching it's
all an act
I interviewed Norma for terror who was
his top aide for 26 years when she
joined the organization there were only
seven other employees she knew him
better than anybody on both the business
and the social side and she said there
are two Donald Trump's one is the one
you see on TV who makes these outrageous
comments to get attention for his brand
and even if it creates negative
publicity he still becomes the center of
attention every day both in conversation
and for the media but then there's the
other Donald Trump the one that insiders
know who's just the opposite he's
thoughtful he listens he's very careful
about making decisions the Hispanic
Chamber of Commerce during the campaign
called for a boycott of his properties
over his remarks about the border in
Mexico and a month or two later the head
of it met with Donald and he emerged and
he told CNN my god he was thoughtful he
listened I was so surprised that sums up
the difference you say in your book this
was a fascinating read by the way that
sometimes he's generous and supportive
and as you described listen as well and
other times he's fairly angry and
abusive with staff yeah you know he he
does have these tirades when he was at
merrill ago and Martha Stewart showed up
one day and his Butler Tony cynical
opened the door and Martha said do you
think I could take a tour of merrill ago
and Tony said sure we'll set up for
three o'clock the next day and Donald
came in and
he told them and I also had great take
care of her but then later in the day
Tony went to see if Donald needs
anything in his private quarters and
that'll just blew up and I'm screaming
at him
you dumbass you should have scheduled it
for noon when the club members would be
here and they would see Martha Martha
would see them just out of control
at that moment Melania walked in and she
said to Donald I don't think he should
be talking to Tony madtown and that
gives you a clue about the relationship
that she will express your views he does
listen the next day both Tony and Donald
were in the living room of merrill ago
and Trump handed Tony two thousand
dollars in $20 bills would you believe
so that was his apology on the one hand
he will fly off the handle on the other
hand you know he won't hold a grudge and
just a little snippet of milania's
relationship
and by the way Melania one of the new
items in the book is that she is really
a powerful age you will sit in on
meetings she'll offer her views
summarize what others have said come up
with a new strategy and I quote on the
record people like Reince Priebus saying
that her judgment is impeccable and
that's the one thing they all agree on
that she is a class act
I found the Melania Trump chapter
fascinating too I was really glad that
you put that down for more people to
absorb you also talked though you won't
went back in that short chapter to when
she appeared on Howard Stern's program
and talked about wild sex everyday and
you talked about Donald Trump's quote
about her proportion and her her boobs
why did you exceed all that in one
chapter on Melania if you're trying to
say that she's credible like that well
there's nothing wrong with good boobs
and furthermore it sells books and I
think everyone on the male side at least
appreciates Maria's appearance I
certainly do
there you go and I've seen her in a
bikini and at the pool at merrill ago
and she looks even more gorgeous in
person also when you see them together
you realize this is a marriage that's
going to last I mean they're very
involved with discussions they laugh and
tease with each other I recently saw
them the night before New Year's Eve the
party that we went to my wife Pam and I
who's also a former Washington Post
reporter at merrill ago and they were
they were just having a very very
impassioned just got impassioned
discussion and and and just having a
wonderful time with each other that
marriage is going to last that's great
so you have been an author with the
Washington Post back when Watergate was
the hot topic talk about your trajectory
of your career writing 21 books now what
what do you think about the mainstream
media and what do you think about book
writing well I am having a ball writing
books I was in the Washington Post for
15 years I sat next to Woodward and
Bernstein during Watergate
it was the Wall Street Journal before
that and started writing books and I
just loved exploring new areas that are
secretive whether it's the CIA the FBI
Secret Service that are also powerful
that are also important I did a book on
Palm Beach that's how I first met Trump
I call that my midlife crisis I had to
drink more champagne go to more parties
and Trump and my wife Pam and I flew
down to merrill ago and on the way down
he imitated the nasal constricted tones
of the old guard the bluebloods
condemning his club mayor a lot Mara
Lago because it admits Blacks and Jews
to this day some clubs in Palm Beach do
not admit blacks and Jews and he said I
love I want to be loved
and I enjoy sticking it to them and that
sort of sums up everything about Donald
Trump he wants to be loved and he enjoys
sticking it to whoever might be in his
way that is the
of one Donald Trump you know people see
him on TV they think they know
everything about him they know very
little this book reveals details that
have never come out about him whether
it's what he uses for hairspray or why
he made decisions about hiring or not
hiring people like Romney Giuliani
Tillerson more recently Bolton he
thought he was too hawkish on the first
go-around and but he doesn't like this
these details come out he doesn't like
people to know that he hands out
hundred-dollar bills to janitors and
workmen as tips when I asked him about
that in the only interview he says he
has given or will give for a book this
took place the night before New Year's
Eve I asked him about the hundred dollar
bills and he said what 100 dollar bills
who who does that who told you that he
was trying to obfuscate he doesn't want
that out he wants to have this tough-guy
image and any any little personal detail
like that or that might show that he's
you know a very compassionate guy
doesn't doesn't want that out but it's
in this book Wow we'll talk about your
interview with the president because it
seems like from the book there might be
of about 11 questions what were what are
you most glad you asked him about and
what looking back do you wish you had
asked mm-hmm there's always a question
you wish you had asked but I sort of hit
on the major points in the book whether
it was the Russia collusion allegations
or what he thinks about Muller or the
economy the improvements you know I say
in the book that that he will be seen as
a great one of the greatest American
presidents just like Reagan who was also
reviled by the media and yet he got rid
of the Soviet Union he boosted the
economy the same with Trump reviled by
the press and the accomplishments are
clear if you look at them without a bias
on the economy lowest unemployment rate
rate in
recorded history Louis black
unemployment rate in recorded history
booming stock market and then on the
Foreign Affairs side almost totally
getting rid of Isis about to meet with
the North Korean leader getting Saudi
Arabia to go after radical Islamic
ideology just remarkable for the any
president but certainly for the first
year and at the same time he has all
these quirks and a strange bizarre
tweets that makes everyone cringe I
think every supporter cringes that some
of these remarks that he makes like
presidents we've ever had but you know
him and you've known him for so long
talk about writing a book on a man that
you know as a friend and who's the
president and you're an independent
journalist with your own credibility how
do you balance that you know I made up
my mind when I wrote this book that I'm
going to be a journalist first as I
always have been and I don't care what
he thinks and and that's the only way to
pursue a book honestly and anybody who
reads the book sees that there are
plenty of negative items plenty of juicy
tidbits but at the same time overall it
is a favorable towards Trump and and
that's because it tells the truth the
book goes into in a chapter called scam
artists the dishonest media it's not
just bias it's real dishonesty where in
one case New York Times had a story
above the fold lead was that rohan
Breuer Lane the model had just met Trump
and he asked her to change out of her
clothes Wow unbelievable and the
headline was you know crossing a line
with women well it turns out that she
had been invited to a pool party at
merrill ago at the last minute and she
didn't have time to go back and change
into a bathing suit so she went to the
party that I don't took a liking to her
he offered to show around the estate he
offered a bathing suit you want to bathe
in suit yeah so she might
bathroom put on a bikini came out and
started going out with him for quite a
few months but guess where the fact that
they went out together was in that story
the sixteenth paragraph the sixteenth
paragraph and the story portrayed it as
a demeaning and demeaning and encounter
she said he was he was wonderfully this
gentleman and and they started going
together that's the to me it's like
robbing a bank it's it's so dishonest
and when I was at the Washington Post
during Watergate I would have been fired
if I did anything like that
absolutely quite no question that's how
the media have changed and what I do is
I present specific examples whether it's
about the collusion allegations or any
other issue in on collusion you know the
Washington Post Rihanna's story
August 14th of last year which quoted
emails that have been turned over by the
White House to congressional committees
among the various campaign aides
including Manafort Papadopoulos this
minor aide was trying to get them to go
to Russia and meet with Russian
leadership and metaphors in the email
said no we're not going to do this and
his deputy gates said no we're not going
to do this and Manafort said we have to
warn trump not to do this and Manafort
said I want this guy to make sure that
nobody in the campaign has anything to
do with Russians I never read that until
it wasn't there believable have you seen
that anywhere no it's ignored it's
ignored by The Washington Post and even
the Washington Post story had a headline
Trump a tried to get aides to go to
Russia not the real story which was
Trump aids don't want to have anything
to do with Russia that is the bottom
line on the whole collusion story well
let's talk about the media because you
do put a lot of examples in the book as
you as you just described where they
seem to have no bounds for discrediting
destroying driving negative
narratives on Donald Trump it's as if
for president Trump think he could do no
wrong but for Donald Trump he can do no
right what's your sense of what's
driving this in the mainstream media
that you're part of well first of all
there's a bias against Republicans in
general you know with Reagan he was
portrayed as stupid or dangerous well
the same thing with Trump he still put
in dangerous according to the media and
and they just can't break out of that
you know I think if they if they feel
that if they did they would be
ostracized by their colleagues I know
for example from people within the White
House Correspondents cabal that among
themselves they laugh at him they mock
him that is the overriding theme you
know many people just inherently can't
think independently and in fact that's
one reason I left college after two
years like a few other people Michael
Dell and and gates I didn't want to be
told how to think anyone he told what to
read I wanted to get first-hand what
actually happened and and that's the way
I've operated I don't have blinders on
I'd like to penetrate secret secrets and
that's what I've done in this book with
all these details about the real Donald
it's excellent it's really a fun read so
explain what happened with Reince
Priebus and Paul Ryan and Chris Christie
during the Access Hollywood important
weekend for the campaign what did they
do and then was there any repercussions
from what they did later well keep in
mind that Reince Priebus still went to
the debate he still supported Trump
through the RNC he actually didn't you
know withdraw any support
What did he say What did he say
let's see he said you can get out of the
race or lose in a huge landslide and you
mentioned this in your book I'm history
and mm-hmm but that didn't but he was
made chief of staff yeah but at the same
time Trump never forgave him for
for saying that which is unfortunate
because Trump because rights really
presided over so many of these successes
including the deregulation that has led
CEOs to realize that they can expand and
hire more workers that they're not going
to be restricted and constricted and a
lot of other achievements that occurred
under under Reince Priebus
but but one point on the access
hollywood tape is that you know Hillary
has said that it shows that Trump is is
a coercive marauder but actually what he
is saying in the tape is women are after
him all the time and you know he takes
advantage of that when you're a star
they want you to do that so it's not
it's not it's not non-consensual
activity it is consensual activity that
he describes Wow
well you know it wasn't anything that
really has happened in politics in my
lifetime in your lifetime so we saw
something that doesn't usually happen
usually it would be the death knell of a
of a presidential campaign and Paul Ryan
the speaker seemed to act that way and
looking back what is it that they didn't
understand whether it was Reince Priebus
there Paul Ryan about the Trump voter
and the Trump base about these things
about Donald Trump well I think I think
rice did understand but it is very hard
for people in certain circles and the
East and the West
to understand the way the average voter
thinks my home contractor working-class
person said to me I don't care what
Trump says I just care about what he
does and that I think sums up the way
people in the so-called working class
thing they have to be judged by results
if a carpenter nails a nail into into
and it's crooked he may be fired a
Harvard professor can spout off about
all kinds of things he's never held
accountable these people understand
results and that's what you see with
Donald Trump yeah I think I see a point
and that was great in your book let's
talk about Palm Beach it was it was
alien to me but you write that behind
the hedges the games that Palm Beaches
play their affairs scams murder snubs
intrigues jealousies pretenses bigotry
and occasional generosity make the CMAs
TV shows look like nursery tales talk
about how Donald Trump came into
mar-a-lago and his whole personality how
he took that place and how its resulted
today Trump first heard about merrill
ago from his limousine driver and this
is typical he'll go around asking people
their opinions whether they're chamber
maids or Secret Service agents you know
he has his advisors but he also has a
wide canvass of people who give him
opinions as well as about 12 friends
that he consults I named them in the
book most of them are billionaires but
that is the way he works
when I was at Merrill ago recently with
him he asked me what I thought about
Israeli settlements I know as much about
the Middle East as he knows about the
Talmud but I gave my opinion and that's
that's the way he operates but he was
enthralled by merrill ago and he bought
it at bargain basement price it was a
white elephant at first he used it as
his home but then he decided to turn it
into a club and that was the idea of
Paul rampell his lawyer in Florida who
is Jewish and said you know you can
admit Jews and blacks these other clubs
don't do that it can be profit-making
and sure enough now it's worth seven
hundred million dollars
Marla Donald's second wife was against
turning it into a club she just wanted
it for herself but but he went ahead
with it the one thing
she did contribute what she said he
should have a spa and and so he created
Trump Spa at merrill ago but but it is
paradise as he says it's the closest
thing to paradise you'll ever get to it
is simply unbelievable it overlooks both
sides of the island which is only about
a half mile wide at the widest point and
this this culture is is unique I mean
it's the richest place in the world it
has these traditions Red Cross ball
spent all the time at charities
developing these these balls in the end
they don't actually produce that much
money
one club member but they never Jonah
Lehane ur was married to a very wealthy
real estate guy from Italy and
eventually he died and left her about
three hundred million dollars
well she stored his body at a local
funeral home for 40 days under eyes
because she said I wanted to enjoy the
season as they call it the season i I
was faithful faithful to him and and now
I want to enjoy myself and go to the
parties go to the party on the yacht
with with Eva Ivana and in fact she said
she's going to do the same thing to her
second husband if if he dies as well
this is Palm Beach Wow
I don't think I don't think many spouses
would go for that maybe in Palm Beach so
it's incredible I'm talk about the flag
that he had a battle with Palm Beach
people about down there yep Donald
erected this huge huge flag just
towering over merrill ago towering over
the street and the town said this is
against dont zoning regulations but he
went to battle and said it was a free
speech issue he sued the town
and they started finding him a huge
amount of money every day eventually
they settled and he agreed to move the
flagpole further away from the street
and to reduce the length of the flagpole
but guess what he erected it on a mound
that that his workmen created so that in
the end it was just as high as it was
before this is typical Donald Trump and
as he would say as he says he always
wins not quite but usually does and the
way he finagle to get the club approved
by the town is sort of typical of how he
operates on the one hand Paul Rempel his
lawyer sent copies of gentlemen's
agreement and another similar movie to
the town council members who were trying
to prevent him from turning this into a
club implying that they're all bigots
and that's why they were against
approving the club at the same time he
sued the town and he invited these town
council members to parties at merrill
ago he said we're gonna have these
glamorous girls and you know and he also
played golf with them and tennis with
them so he uses the carrot and the stick
and eventually it worked her logo brings
in about 30 almost 40 million dollars a
year everybody wants to go there now
that sort of sums up the way Trump
operates do you happen to know if
there's any blacks or Jewish members oh
yeah you know my wife Pam and I have
been there dozens of times we go to the
Newseum parties we have dinner there and
there are a large number of Jews and a
sprinkling of blacks as as members Wow
well there must be repercussions from
the way he boldly and brashley came into
that place and and yet I guess they just
enjoy the party so much that they've
gotten over whatever hurt feelings
well you know in the end Palm Beach
people like success and and obviously
he's successful you know at first they
they they sniff that no he doesn't wear
the traditional blue blazer he doesn't
have the traditional rolls-royce and
steady drives a Lamborghini he boasts
about his money oh my god that's
terrible
so he was everything that prime Beach
hates but now they've come to see that
that you know an invitation mera Lago is
incredible
so his wingspan is gigantic in the sense
that you saw so many working-class and
ordinary citizens vote for him maybe it
was in contrast to Hillary Clinton we
may not know that but from very wealthy
people as a wealthy person himself to
his resonance with ordinary Americans
what do you think about that well the
one hand he hits themes that people feel
very strongly about you know he is a
patriot the fact that he attacked
Kaepernick over his kneeling when the
national anthem was played
I think resonated with a lot of people
of course that was after the campaign
but but those are very very heartfelt
feelings that most Americans have at the
same time he's he's likable you know
he's very candid he'll make these side
remarks and for example with the Chinese
leader you know he would say I didn't
get anything out of him so he's
appealing and and people like that as
well and that's quite different from
Hillary who by the way treated her
Secret Service agents with such disdain
that being assigned to her detail was
considered a form of punishment this is
from my previous book the first family
detail where's Trump and his family
treat the agents with respect I asked
Trump at merrill ago overlooking the
pool how do you like being protected by
the Secret Service
and he said it's wonderful you know I'll
have 20 agents and I'll be playing golf
and
they're all looking in different
directions and if I miss a shot they
don't see it and by the way Baron is
also very respectful of his agents
unlike Jenna and Barbara Bush who would
try to lose their agents was was nasty
to Asians and Baron is a very good
garius guy he'll he'll go around at
merrill ago on the terrace where we're
breakfast and dinner are served and I'll
say enjoy your breakfast have a good day
just like Trump you know he's a like a
great maitre d and I have anecdotes
about him for example going back to when
Baron was 2 years old
Melania was feeding him the bottle in
the plane and the pilot Mike Donovan
walked back into the cabin copilot was
was flying and Baron was having you know
the bottle and Baron took the bottle out
of his mouth and said to Mike Donovan
once I'm Mike that's amazing
so talk about the code names that the
Secret Service have for the first family
the code names for for Secret Service
protectees are generated by a computer
randomly but and they get rid of some
words that may be hard to understand or
you know might be problems but then in
addition each protectee can choose his
own word or her own word and Melania and
Trump have chosen their own words
Trump is mogul and the Dick Cheney was
let's note Dick Cheney's wife Lynne was
off author she was an author and and the
purpose is that when agents are speaking
into their little mouthpieces and
earpieces that they don't want others to
overhear who they're talking about and
also they don't want to have confusion
over the names so if they have a
particular
like like Eagle which was Clinton that's
a very clear-cut name great well you
know any White House has its warring
factions but this White House seems to
have a lot of them and it reminds me of
the parable about the elephant and the
blind men that for somebody trying to
report and understand what's happening
in any White House you have to have
enough confidence that you're touching
all the parts of the elephant as a blind
person coming in I'd say but do you feel
confident that you were capturing and
reporting on all the all the different
warring factions and who are they well
they're all worried and I believe that I
was able to get right inside because
there are as you say there are many
satellite people and they hear things
and they gossip and they report a leak
but when you actually are inside they're
getting the people who are with Trump
all through the day that gives you I
think the correct story and and combine
that with with knowing Trump for two
decades and also knowing about the White
House Secret Service all that came
together so that I think I was able to
present an accurate portrayal which says
that he will be seen as one of the
greatest presidents but at the same time
includes all of the warts all of the
tensions and the personal details that
make you understand how he thinks how he
operates things that he doesn't want you
to know because he will pull this
curtain over himself to prevent anybody
from knowing anything besides his
tough-guy image well what have we
learned about the lessons learned from
the people who have left the team
already whether they're staff or whether
they're cabinet secretaries what do you
think about why they laugh about why
they left and what it
what he's what he's trying to clean up
what are the problems that he sees that
he doesn't want to round him well you
know when they took when they talk now
about him resetting the White House and
and changing the direction of the aides
that there is something to that and that
is in the first go-round he would listen
to a lot of recommendations for example
condi rice recommended Tillerson but now
he's saying to himself I want people
that I really feel compatible with that
I am comfortable with who are smart who
are basically on my wavelength obviously
they're not always going to agree but
but that is what he's going for and I
think I think that'll work out well why
did he reach out to Mitt Romney
you touch on that in the book a little
bit but it was confusing to people who
voted for Trump after everything Mitt
Romney said about don't try Romney was
pushed by Steve Bannon who liked
Romney's position on China and also
Reince Priebus thought it was that he
would be a good idea and and Trump said
well he looks the part Trump is very big
on appearance as you might imagine and
so he met with him and at first he was
very unimpressed Romney confided that he
hadn't really prepared because he wasn't
really thinking he would actually get
the job they met a second time he was
prepared but in the end there are all
these considerations about who had
supported him who was loyal and in the
end Giuliani was Secretary of State
Trump wanted him to be Attorney General
he didn't want that Giuliani was not as
big a supporter as sessions was sessions
was a big supporter everyone around said
sessions were perfect so even though
Trump had reservations about sessions as
Attorney General he did appoint him as
Attorney General he still you know makes
side remarks about him even though
sessions is doing a fantastic job as
Attorney General in terms of Trump's
agenda
but those are the some of the little
inside insights so what about the
difference between John Kelly and Reince
Priebus what do you see as different
Chiefs of Staff examples how was the
lesson learned from number one trump has
given Kelley much more authority he
never really gave Reince the authority
to be chief of staff and so everybody
was just sort of doing their own thing
and they didn't have to go through riots
Kelley is supposedly the chief of staff
but at the same time Trump goes around
him as well Trump in the end is the
chief of staff and and he will fret
about any kind of restriction that Kelly
puts on him he doesn't like it when
Kelly says you you know you can't see
your daughter unless you go through me
no that's not very good so so there's
always this friction that goes on you
also talked about Kellyanne Conway who
uh number of us have known for years but
it was very negative you said that her
jobs both campaign manager and in the
White House were really in name only
that they were there wasn't much
substance there and that she was the
number one leaker to the press yeah
house how's that going because the
people I come in contact with don't
don't see it that way well she obviously
is a brilliant commentator on TV in
terms of presenting his policies I have
always admired her I've known her a long
time as well but when I interviewed her
at the White House and it was recorded
she started lashing into these
colleagues and and she apparently had
forgotten that she was on the record and
she said these really nasty things about
Reince Priebus that were obviously
untrue and also about Jared and Ivanka
that their their leakers I didn't
include exactly what she said about
Reince Priebus because I felt it would
be unfair because when you put someone
like that in even if you say it's untrue
some people start to believe it but she
also also aides have said to me that
they have seen text messages that she
has sent to reporters in which
leaks and makes disparaging remarks so
really you know it's a wholesale leak
source and I call her the number-one
leaker in the White House and and that
is not good you know because of course
it means that nothing can be kept
confidential it's not that she's leaking
national security information but but
it's very hard for a White House to
operate if if everything is is leaked
you talk about I hope Hicks to and you
said that she's a trump whisperer but
that there's a lot of billionaires who
are friends of President Trump who have
asked to be set up with her and that he
refuses to do it say more
yeah well that's about how there is
except that you know she obviously is
very likable she's a big supporter of
Trump she's beautiful but she I don't
think I know this has not come out
before but but she actually chose to
cooperate with the person who wrote what
I call a novel mr. wolf who wrote
firearm fury I mean most of that is just
fiction and I know Steve Bannon fed him
some of that stuff for example the book
says that when the 25th the remarks that
Trump made at the New Jersey Golf Club
which were about Charlie charlottesville
that Steve Danon thought that he could
be removed under the 25th amendment
because of mental impairment I was
interviewing Bannon at that time right
in the middle of the controversy when
Trump was in New Jersey and he said that
he talked to him twice on the phone and
egged him on he said it was wonderful
what he was saying don't retract it if
you do the press will just jump on you
so just one little example I know a lot
of the other items are just obviously
untrue
you know the Trump never wanted to run
that well I didn't wanted him to run
that they were unhappy that they wanted
you know that she was in tears
when they won unbelievable yeah all he
did was look at the TV set and you saw
how overjoyed she was and overjoyed
Trump was so it's just silly but you
know some people want to just believe
these things or they can't figure out
the different difference between truth
and falsehood and you know that's fine
but but hope did elect to cooperate with
him even though his track record is he
writes for these liberal publications
like Vanity Fair and now why would a
conservative white White House cooperate
with an author like that in your book
you talk about how President Trump talks
to the mainstream journalists from New
York Times and Washington Post I mean
there's a lot of reaching out to people
who don't have his best interest in mind
what do you think about all that on the
one hand Trump recognizes that these are
the publication's with a great impact so
if he has a message to let out then
he'll call in New York Times or The
Washington Post but then at the same
time in his usual fashion there's always
some other message going on and that is
he'll attack those papers which is
something that the base likes and that
gets some attention and so he uses a
two-track system okay let's talk about
the Teflon aides who are they and what
kind of things that you you think that
some of them have done some real damage
to the presidency you know obviously
Jared Kushner and Ivanka are very well
intentioned they do contribute some good
things for example Jared came up with
the idea of going to Saudi Arabia first
during their Middle East trip to send a
message to Arab countries but they're
both naive and they have been
responsible for the most disastrous and
foolish decisions of the trump
presidency namely higher firing Jim
Comey is FBI director which led to the
appointment of Muller as Special Counsel
Jared thought that this would be great
because the Democrats would like it in
other words he had this you know
political view that this would be a way
to
to Democrats well of course was the
office of the Democrats attacked Trump
and still are over that and they decided
that scare Moochie would be the best PR
person they thought that he would
burnish their image their very image
conscious and they were solely
responsible for bringing Anthony scare
Moochie and and that has to be the worst
hiring decision in the history of the
White House but because they're family
you know he's not going to fire them he
has a hard time firing people anyway
anywhere personally and he'll have
somebody else do it or he'll just make
their lives miserable
and in the case of Jared and Ivanka he
does say to them you know maybe you
should go back to New York and he's
hinted that maybe they are problems but
they are not leaving and that's why I
call him the Teflon aides okay and the
vice president what's his role you said
that in your book you say that he has a
knack of getting in the in the
background
yeah the woodwork you know whenever
there's a controversy that erupts over
some of trumps comments he sort of fades
into the woodwork he's very good at that
but he obviously contributes not
tremendously on especially the
legislative front and most important of
all he he doesn't attract attention and
that's very important to Donald Trump so
he's learned how to work with them well
yeah he they have a good relationship
and Trump respects him so with all the
death threats and the hatred fomented by
the left against President Trump talk
about the implications of that 26 year
old who got in over the fence and was in
for quite a long time it wasn't revealed
for a while and what is it about this
culture and the personnel of the Secret
Service that puts present trumpet
greater risk
you know Secret Service has had this
very very disastrous culture of laxness
of covering up problems agents who
report problems are essentially punished
they're not
advanced and they have this attitude of
we make do with less they're proud to
not spend money on you know the latest
the lasers to detect intruders at the
White House but you can imagine what
kind of culture that might be in any law
enforcement agencies especially where
where the agents feel that they can't
report real problems and so this has led
to one Fiasco after another going back
to the so I he's prancing into the state
dinner even though they were not invited
Obama never fired the Secret Service
over over that or other intrusions
including Gonzalez who went all the way
into the White House and then the Secret
Service lied about that and said he
didn't get into the way to the White
House and he wasn't armed even though he
was imagine you know a law enforcement
agency lying like that publicly and and
then there was this intrusion that you
mentioned where this individual was able
to get right up to the windows of the
White House and peer inside and the new
director appointed by President Trump
mister Alice is just clueless you know
he was brought in thinking that he would
change the culture and he's just bought
into the culture and has the best
example he proposed to the White House
diminishing the number of people who
were protected family members and White
House staff taking protection away in
order to save money Kay magic I mean the
whole budget of the Secret Service is
two billion dollars and a lot of that is
for financial crimes investigation what
could be more important than protecting
the life of the president you know an
assassination nullifies democracy and
yet he proposed saving money to take
protection away from failing members and
and staff it was immediately shot down
by horrified White House staff but but
that tells you so much about why this
guy needs to be replaced before a
tragedy occurs Wow and that
said that the president Trump had
someone else in mind I can't remember
how this guy ended up getting the job
well you know Trump wanted another
individual who is now chief chief
operating officer of The Secret Service
but but it was the chief of staff mr.
mr. Kelly who who was absolutely
insistent that Alice be appointed they
knew each other from you know the
military and just just a total total
disaster who is pretty much ignored by
agents because you know they understand
he doesn't know what he's doing so let's
talk about the Trump resistance I mean
the left i I've never seen anything like
what's out there outside these walls
both culturally and politically so with
all that's geared up against this man
what would happen if the right would
have done this for President Obama and
developed a resistance across the
culture across legal lanes across the
political obstruction yeah it's just two
different worlds that seem to be
tolerated in America are we losing the
civility of a legitimate election a duly
elected president being able to govern
of course if this were done with Obama
they would all be called racists and and
by the way remember that Obama has spent
20 years listening to Reverend Wright
who is anti America anti-white
anti-israel had him as his the person
who officiated as wedding called
amusement mentor comedian if Donald
Trump went to one service like that and
did not walk out immediately he would be
he would be toast in the media and so a
lot of it does have to do with the media
and and how they portray everything a
lot of it I think has to do with you
know let mean instinct you know a lot of
people just sort of go along with the
people that they know and friends and
some people just feel very sanctimonious
they feel good about them
if they denounced someone like Trump
they I think they they look good if they
do that and others you know legitimately
have those political views and and I
keep far away from getting into any
arguments with any of my liberal friends
or my liberal family members you know I
think it's like an ego trip - thank you
you can or should try to convince
someone of of your own political views
of course I'm able to write books and
and present political views that I that
may or may not comport with somebody
else but that's that's the age we live
in now tactically though you look at
those economic boycotts they were trying
to hurt him financially even before the
election and right after the election
they were trying to feed boycotts of
anything by Ivanka Trump the as you said
in Charlottesville after those comments
there were a number of charities who
pulled out of Mara Lago I mean they're
using different tactics the center-left
I would say then then we've seen I don't
I don't see them being used on the
center-right but maybe I just don't see
it yeah you know of course he gives them
ammunition by making some of his
outrageous comments but it is a
situation where they ignore the results
you know and it was the blacks think
he's he's a bigot and yet it's the
lowest unemployment rate among blacks in
recorded history you know you just can't
account for it for people
misunderstanding but I think over time
they will you know over time as in the
case of Reagan Reagan and when Gallup
poll was rated as the number one
greatest president and yet remember the
way he was portrayed in the media demon
he's going to he's going to ruin the
world
I think the same change will occur with
Trump and his tweets talk about the
Trump tweets well as Trump told me and
interview hmm if he had not been
tweeting he would not be president it's
a way of getting around the mainstream
media and it's a way of connecting with
common people with his own vernacular
which is often misspelled and in the
morning he'll start tweeting on his own
he only sleeps four hours a night and
then he'll start tweeting and he'll read
by the way a lot of the major papers you
know he according to that novel by
Michael Wolfe doesn't read well he reads
the Washington Post cover to cover their
x cover to cover Wall Street Journal
cover to cover
in addition Washington Times op eds he
will have things printed out from other
public publications and in tonight's
sites like Breitbart have you know this
I was able to get right to the heart of
the whole issue here and find out you
know what he want to eats on the plane
Chuy's whatever that is and our purse
right and of course well-done steaks the
most wonderful prime steaks are served
at merrill ago and yet he'll have them
well done and reagan do the same thing
fascinating
it's just chock-full with lots of things
okay russian collusion you say in your
book it turns out that in the thousands
of stories about Russian collusion there
was indeed a smoking gun in Reverse
explain you know this minor aid
Papadopoulos emailed the campaign aides
including Menem Manafort and those
emails were turned over by the White
House to congressional committees and
the Washington Post on and not such a
bad place because I used to work there
ran a story last August 14th which
quoted these emails and in them this
minor rate is saying he wants the
campaign to meet with Russian leadership
and Manafort said absolutely not in the
emails
absolutely not we're not going to do
this his depth
the gates that absolutely not we're not
going to do this they said we have to
make sure that Trump never does this and
they instructed another individual and
campaign to make sure that nobody
responds to any requests like this so
what more do you need to know about
Russian collusion these are the people
in charge the campaign saying we want
nothing to do with Russians and yet at
this story has been totally ignored by
the media including by The Washington
Post and The Washington Post had a
headline of aid to Trump wanted meetings
with Russian leaders no the the the real
story was the campaign did not want to
meet with any Russian leaders it's so
unbelievable so why does that happen is
it editors or is it I mean I know
there's bias but in the old days as you
said you wouldn't have gotten away with
this kind of thing so who's letting it
happen you know Washington Post does run
a lot of stories that are fair but I
think it's first of all reporters who
have a liberal leaning and then they
feel that you know writing anything
positive about Trump is is some kind of
bad mark on them and and their
colleagues are going to look down on
them I mean you know I've been
interviewed by for this book by
mainstream reporters who just sort of
snicker when I say anything positive you
know in other words I must be a fool for
saying that tone of voice is is snarky
you know it's it's like you know it's
like young women used to go around with
belly buttons that were exposed they
thought that was fashionable even though
most the time and look terrible I think
of it that way that it's sort of a fad
and you know silly as that sounds
some people just just cannot or will not
look at the facts and make their own
decisions well as we're sitting here you
know it says if the media has thrown
everything they could at this man and
yet I mean even recently stormy Daniels
came out and everyone was worried is
this the next
shoe that's going to cause a real
problem his poll numbers are his
approval ratings going up since this has
happened so if something is different I
mean you can throw all that at him but
yet as you're saying the people must
have their own mind or they must be
discounting the media yeah exactly yeah
and I would say about that that these
alleged activities occurred more than 10
years ago and I conclude from that that
he has gotten older and wiser since then
so but early on in the relationship
between Trump and Melania she found out
that he had seen another woman his
former girlfriend Carol young and she
was going to be going to mera Lago with
him that day she broke up broke up with
him on the spot she didn't care about
the billions of dollars broke up with
him goodbye
ordered the butler at merrill ago tony
senticles who sent her clothes back from
Errol I go to her but a week later he
had wood her back and she told Tony
she's sending her clothes back to
Merrill ago a wonderful little vignette
about Melania is on the apprentice they
were filming in their apartment at Trump
Tower and Donald was there and Lonnie
was there sipping champagne and one of
the contestants said to said Melania
you're very lucky and she Melania motion
over towards Trump and said and he's not
lucky so this this is a really sharp
woman with a great sense of humor
everybody who has any encounter with
hers is impressed she has a tremendous
resonance out there and so I'm glad that
you're doing your part of showing a side
that doesn't get shown so let's talk
about the Secret Service a secret bunker
that's on the North Lawn you say that
it's classified and the things that you
also talk about about protecting the
president I wonder is that making him at
risk are you saying too much to expose
some of what you do how do you make the
judgment calls wrong well I certainly
would not reveal anything that was about
to happen that might undercut some
operation but some of these things are
just not going to cause any harm the
fact that there's a secret bunker under
the North Lawn is something that TV
crews you know pondered and and and
showed and there's even though it is
classified it's very low classification
and and the same with the Secret Service
I think it's important to expose the
problems in the Secret Service in order
to get an eventual you know revolution
to change this this agency to reform
this agency it is so dangerous the fact
that that they relaxed and in fact going
back to the Ronald Reagan assassination
attempt the reason that Hinckley was
able to shoot Reagan and almost kill him
was that the White House staff pressured
the Secret Service to allow bystanders
to see Reagan as he came out of the
Hilton unscreened so Hinckley was 15
feet away from him and was able to shoot
him because the Secret Service and the
Secret Service covered up their own
laxness they never should have bowed to
that pressure these are the secrets that
are so important for people to know
because you know the last thing we want
is an assassination I don't care what
party the person is with so in the last
couple minutes what do you think
president Trump would say if he read
your book well how would he grade it
what would he like wouldn't what
wouldn't he like well when I thought it
graphed the book to him I start page 276
at the last page which says that he will
be seen as one of the greatest
presidents and he'll definitely like
that but I have heard that the White
House communications people are saying
that that the book is viewed favorably
by the White House and as a positive
book even though it has so many
criticisms and and stumbles so I think
that's the way the Donald
has regarded my writing all the way
along you know he's like my articles
regardless of the fact that for example
I sent him one of my articles
demonstrating that Obama was in fact
born in the United States you know based
on the fact that there was an
announcement run of his birth in the
Hawaii paper
I sent him that he knows that he was not
born in Kenya but it suited his
political purposes but at the same time
you know he has a bigger picture and and
understands that I'm an honest
journalist and tell it like it is that's
what I try to do what's your next book I
think this will keep me busy for a long
time the publicity has been analyst and
I'm not thinking about the next book yet
but always looking for tips and
suggestions great to be with you thank
you